eunice is
in new jersey hey eunice how are you hi
how are you better than i deserve what's
up
um okay so really quickly i
um i have about 54 000 in student debt i
got married two years ago
my husband makes the bulk of the money
in our household he's in accounting
so he controls the money that comes in
um
before we get married my plan and i
expressed that to him was the fact that
i wanted to be out of debt as soon as
possible but
as we're talking more and more it just
seems like a student loan
is taking more and more of a back seat
and
i am kind of scared because i want to be
debt-free i don't like
the loans i don't have credit card debts
or anything like that
um it looks like for the fall i may have
to take more loans because
well kovit wiped out my job that kind of
funded
my semesters and um i just don't know
how to
how old are you oh i'm 44.
okay you're talking a lot in
i is there not a we
here because you're married and so
this this idea of he controls the money
and
you might have to take out a loan for
your school um
you got a roommate or a husband yeah
well
that's the thing it's more like i feel
more like it's
all about what he says that goes is he
controlling in
other subjects huh how controlling is he
in other subjects
uh pretty much um i'll tell you
he makes the final decision on things
um we've had this discussion and had
blown out about it but
um it's pretty strong-willed and
um but when it comes to my own i just
don't want that to be in the back burner
i'm not paying alone for 10 years
and um i just don't know how to purchase
this subject
one of the rules i learned a long time
ago eunice is the financial problems
including when i had them
are very seldom the actual problem
they're usually the symptoms so your
loan is not really the problem it's the
symptom
do you think john absolutely this has um
with all due respect units this doesn't
have
much to do with the payment the the
payment
the repayment structure on your student
loan um this has to do with
a man in your life that is not honoring
you is not valuing your voice at the
table for
whatever reason um and
is like in to use your words is
controlling the way you move about
the world and your voice sounds heavy
it yeah oh well
it is frustrating and um is this new
behavior is it
did it emerge after you got married or
is this something that is you kind of
knew walking into the door
front door um no i
we've known each other a long time it's
just that
how old is he 40.
how long has he been in accounting um
quite a while maybe are you guys in a
good church
i go to the church he does not
not often at all okay i would suggest
that you sit with your pastor
and that he have them suggest a good
faith-based marriage
counselor and have that counselor give
you
some verbage to entice your
new husband into the marriage
counselor's office
because if you don't one of two things
is going to happen
you're going to lose who you are
and surrender to a toxic situation or
you're going to divorce one of the two
yeah if you do not solve this and i
think it can be healed it could be as
simple as he's a very detailed
very uh he's a guy who controls the
controllables he's an accountant okay
he's an engineer type
and that that person can uh see
what they're doing is an act of love um
but
they also need to understand that what
they're doing is toxic is crud
because in talking to you i'm um i'm
almost a little afraid for you
oh
um yeah
hey hey are you okay are you okay in
that house
yeah i am okay no no no i i am
um i'm just checking this just this
situation
i i mean the personalities definitely
are yeah clashing but
this situation definitely is yeah but
but i think what we're saying is is the
the student loan problem
and the you having to take out a loan
problem and him controlling all the flow
of cash in the household
are all toxic relational behaviors long
before their financial issues
do you understand that yeah yeah okay
let's let's treat that let's work on
that i want you to
take yourself out for coffee um and i
want you to take a pen and a paper
not even a computer i'll take a pen and
paper and i want you to write down
your feelings i want you to write down
your
what's being controlled what are the
things that you're not able to say out
loud what are the things that
are leaning on you and squashing you and
take that to a marriage counselor take
that to your pastor
and read it to him yeah and then let's
get some help
and maybe we can turn this thing around
i hope you can